the organizers for inviting me to speak
so I'm going to talk about something but
I wanted to be presented more in this
program in general and we get some of
the key people who walk in this car
neither to be neither to this workshop
not battle to the bootcamp or to the
program in general so I'm going to talk
about a different perspective that some
people are following and I was trying to
think about the way to do it when I
don't talk just about my stuff but I
guess eventually I'm just going to talk
about my stuff quite a bit of the time
so please especially slow me down when I
talk about other people's stuff okay so
the question that many of us ask many of
us ask yourself is why do deep networks
work so well and two of the kind of
answers that we heard is one that they
have a lot of expressive power possibly
the other one is that they generalize
well and I think after sitting in the
bootcamp we are both little enough we
are all a little unhappy with these
answers I mean I think that you know
Peter and in Sasha were not trying to
oversell the power of the the VC or the
statistical learning theory theory
perspective and you know it was sort of
clear that we don't understand too much
about how does this apply in the in the
deep network set up and and and also not
to see this lecture said you know I have
this lower bound but this lower bound
you know should deliberate function so
you know maybe that's not what we really
seen in in real data so what I'm the
perspective I'm trying to think about
for a few years and many people have
started thinking about it even well
before me and maybe a better explanation
is it's about the data and some of the
claim is that they work well for data
that is generated in somehow a deep way
on its own right so the data is
generated in some hierarchical fashion
and aside Arkell fashion is the reason
that deep Nets walkways so that's the
perspective that I'm going to talk to
taking this talk
good okay so let's try to think what
does it mean so what are our goal so
good so I'll go so let me just maybe
take a step back I think most of the
talks in this in this workshop on this
bootcamp are saying okay people in
practice these days apply deep net and
do some volume of gradient descent and
they get great results let's try to
understand why this happened
or maybe let's try to tweak the
parameters a little bit to do a little
better my perspective is different I'm
not trying to say I mean even though
this is one of the goals of the POC I'm
not trying to say I'm going to come up
with a great theory of super gradual
descent which I'm going to sell to the
Google people it was making me a
millionaire and you know things will be
classified 0.01% better that's not my
goal here my goal is to take a step back
and try to understand you know in the
big picture somehow why why do we need
something like deep nets to go that's
the good one to understand data models
that seem reasonable that explain why
deep nets work okay so what do we mean
by that so it's not really clear but
I'll tell you the perspectives I chose
for this talk and maybe before the
perspective let me tell you why would
this make us happy so first of all you
know you know we had many talks that
where it was clear that we really want
to understand why and when deep networks
works and why not you know in
particularly in contexts such as the
settings
it would be good if we can get to verbal
algorithms for influence so what is
provable I'll go it is provable I go if
anybody have done statistics I'm not
going to prove to you that your car is
going to drive not crash what I'm going
to prove to you is that if the data is
generated according to a model that I
specified my algorithm does what it's
supposed to be doing right so that's
what I mean by possible algorithm maybe
even we are if we're very lucky and very
smart we can get
robust provable I'll go with you says
you know it's not only if you were
generated according to the data that the
model of data that you came up with even
if there's some small tweak or
differences your algorithm is still
going to work well and finally some of
formative perspective it's very
interesting to understand why do you
need dips why is that needed why can't
we just use models with two layers what
kind of why can we just use caramels or
something to do whatever way so that's
the dream we're not going to satisfy
this dream today but when I have a dream
this is my dream
all right some people have different
okay let's do that that would be amazing
okay so I'm going to criticize everybody
in the community including myself I'm
going to criticize people in two ways
first of all I'm going to not talk about
many many works that are relevant to
this just because there's no time and I
don't know all of the walks and so on
and so forth so everybody I your friend
by not mentioning please don't be
offended and the second everybody I'm
going to mention I'm going to offend I'm
going to say you know why some of the
criteria are not satisfied so I cannot
just be prepared I'm going to offend
everybody so this is the guitar that I'm
going to consider and as you see there's
going to be some tension between them so
first guitar is somehow in the very
applied side we want a realistic model
of the data right so I don't want to
date a model of the data we say the data
is generated the Colin algebraic variety
with some curvature and you know this
you know I'm imitation I like stuff like
that but this is not updated right so we
want to leave somewhat realistic models
the second key that I want is I want
usable algorithms that can actually
recover the influenced procedure right
so I don't just want to say there's a
local minimum blahblahblah I want to say
that if this is your data it was a
portable algorithm that running so much
time in so much data that does give you
a classifier I don't think we've seen
any talk like that in this workshop but
I want something much much stronger than
what we used to and the third thing
which we sound a little bit just in in
my to stock is depth
I want the proof that depth is needed
I'd you know I can't come up with an
algorithm the twenty sophisticated but
in fact if you're doing our
classification you're done so obviously
there's tension between this list this
video it's the objectives I there's
really think the Morial istic stuff is
the harder it is to model the harder it
is to analyze right so if it's very
realistic I'm not going to be able to do
a task to into entry if I can
reconstruct if I have very efficient
algorithms for reconstruction even if
the model is not completely realistic
you might think that it's actually hard
to be to be able to prove lower bounds
on them right because you know I haven't
I'll go 18 right so if I have not go
even made then maybe the depth doesn't
buy me go to too much right so this
distance objectives are some somewhat in
tension and for the last few years me
and a few other people who are not
represented again in this community are
thinking about this peril maybe from
this perspective some from other
perspective to an attractor
then can we can we answer all of this
question of simple data so that's what
we mean okay so what I'm going to do is
like I said what I'm going to do is
first of all I'm going to offend
everybody in the last 10 or 15 min and
now we are going to come up with my own
model which is not perfect either and
you know and I'm going to offend myself
and then you know it feel free to
participate at anything ok so since we
are the simon say institute for theory
of computing if you're somebody you just
did fill you all your life and somebody
tells you there are these deep nets and
nobody understand why do we need deaths
you raise your hand we said we have sick
at lower bounds i understand why we do
we need depths how many of you have seen
secret lower bounds ok so many of you
have seen say ok what is the secret no
bones let's just make a caricature of
what does it mean in our setting so in
our setting secret lower bands will meet
the following well what is the data the
data is what you like it's X I which is
high dimensional and why I what is the
Exide X is just uniform on the discrete
cube what is the Y the Y is f of X I and
what is the F F is a polynomial size
circuit of depth D ok and what is the
circuit you know in the classical
computational complexity you have and a
unbounded fund and in all gates and you
have not gates ok so that's the model
that we're looking at what do we know so
does the long line of work I'm just
going to summarize it in one slides
maybe in the strongest result so this is
by a row sponsor video and turn and
slightly strengthened by Sahasra to
actually prove the original is thought
not in the probabilistic setup but
here's what they do so there's a long
line of work here which I'm summarizing
but the best result in this area so if
you have a thicket of Sighs for the RAM
of depth D ok so this is what we want
and what do we know what's the death
separation that we get we get that any
circuits g of depth one less D minus one
that classifies almost that classifies
slightly better than Lando so the
probability that G of X is not equal to
f of X which is the correct label is
less than 1/2 minus Epsilon must be of
size exponential in n to the 1 over D so
there are secrets of DMI that's the -
what are secrets of set V I give you a
specific function of depth D this is
going to be my labeling of the data X is
at random
understand the distribution why is just
f of X F is there a very explicit
function and you want to do it with
depth D minus one if you want to do it
in steps minus one and you just wanted
label to classify better than random
then you need you need this very big
size you're good this very strong very
strong a separation is that so let's say
let's ask about this coin and I decided
so you will help me or friend everybody
so Howie allistic is this model of for
data anybody wants to give me a number
no data looks like that so for me this
is your okay is the reconstruction are
going are going for the circuits 0 to 10
thank you yes Leo 210 thank you for last
this is a very good question so you see
a very polite person here he wants to do
this game 0 to 10 and you know so it's
clear but it's not very realistic they
these people didn't think about didn't
think about influence at all they didn't
think about how to reconstruct the
circuits I'm also going to give them
zeal about the construction this is an
explicit construction of one secret but
the depth is the best that you can get
so for me you know again they didn't
think about this we perspective that I
presented at the beginning of the talk
but you know the depth they nailed down
they get 10 right there's no question
about it you cannot do anything better
it's explicit it's under distribution
they didn't think about the construction
at all that wasn't the objective you in
general we know that the constructing
circuit is very hard and it's not very
realistic so I get they get 1000 yes
please yes I agree it's not very
realistic model data but maybe it's a
good model of data with some of the
labels randomized
I'm not sure I mean so there is even an
easier more there where you just label
some of the you knows and some of the
labels are really at random and for this
model much more is known for this model
it's much it's much easier to show that
you'll need a big circuit in order to it
to be to agree with the data so this all
some of stronger is okay so maybe maybe
you right in the sense that even before
this model I could have came up with
come a piece of the even simpler model
where the X is iid chosen from the cube
and the wires completely dependent on
them and then I try to fit a circuit or
any function to fit this data and then
the classical theory of VC dimension or
whatever we tell me that I will need a
very big object in order to do that
right so that spell is a little
different right because what you say
okay there is a generator you know that
the Y is generated in it you know Queens
the pathway from the XS that's a good
comment oh good other questions comments
okay so we're I promise to a friend
everybody's little friend matters so
here is a slide for Mateus talk you know
this the function the deconstruct is
this function that goes up and down many
many times and you will all here so of
course Mateus doesn't think the real
data looks like that but the model if
you want is the following model the XS
are chosen uniform in the interval 0 1 y
is going to be f of X n what is f f is
this explicit oh it's the function that
we've seen over that you know as it goes
up and down exponentially many terms
explicit all the disk well size depth
value network such that any value
network of depth D that agree with F a
lot maybe the probability that the
expected value of the difference Mateus
can get something much better but let's
say just one over Hamid has to be of
size exponential in D okay so that's
we've all seen the construction is very
nice well enjoyed the proof it was great
ok let's still layers coma tools on
these objectives okay so maybe because
you see let me do it I'll do it I won't
ask you to Freddie
so I think in depth I would give him a 9
I won't give him a pen solely because
there is no separation between I mean
this is fantastic but there is no
separation between D and D plus 1 which
is something that he proved support we
would like right so there's just a
separation you know between D and D
square so we lose something
the construction I still BK give him
zero I didn't really think about the
construction that wasn't the objective
and realism is to because athletes at
least it feel valued do you know it
looks more like data model that we will
consider are you going to appeal the
score objection probably not but you
know but still I mean we are we haven't
respected Mateus or anybody else to just
consider universe univariate fractions
like but I mean I'm just using it as an
example if you came up is an example
that's multivariate and real-valued
where you have a good separation between
D and E plus one you know we will get a
score ten here you know I would still
give you zero here and two here or
something but you will get their tender
good okay good so that's that's another
approach
okay the proof is that I can't really
enjoyed it okay let's do a candidate to
cognitive to his hacker models so if you
live in the world of deep nuts
everything is deep net so you say oh you
know the data is also generated by deep
nets we all know that that's the case
everything in life is deep nets either
for influence or for generation so what
are we going to do we are going to use
some model that's reversible where you
generate the data going down you're
going to do the influence going up maybe
you're going to do guns you have a
couple of networks talking to each other
one is going to generate the data one is
going to discriminate you're going to
devotional autoencoders all these
techniques that you say the data is also
in natural okay I don't know this
technique so well so I let you suggest
course so how I mean actually the
hardest Gotham is realism so how how
realistic is the data that is generated
by this business very good right so it's
eight nine ten
so here's what I gave it I gave it on
realism I give it 9 I mean I format I'm
saying at guns that this to me is not
exactly the same this is something that
looks okay but if you look at the
details of something sometimes you mean
sometimes it doesn't really look like
like you want in construction there are
algorithms but we have no proof right so
there I'll go it seems to do all of this
procedures that's why people using them
but we have no proof that they do what
they're supposed to do so let me just
give it to and similarly for Depp's you
freeze like you need depth but we have
no proof that you need Depp's innocent
but smart people have thought about this
before and is that ok maybe we can prove
something in this set up so this is a
very nice paper by Sanjeev over from
about five or six years ago and a bunch
of his collaborator which unfortunately
I didn't write down and they said looked
at random sparse generative models so
something on the board because I didn't
steal any picture from the from the
paper from the slide so what what does
it mean so you have a network well the
basic assumption is that it's very
sparse so the average degree is very low
especially and in their construction the
average degree goes up as you go down
the levels the assumption also when you
go in this direction you start with the
vector that's mostly zero so maybe
there's a little bit of one zero when
you go in this direction the generation
process will have very few ones here and
so on and so forth that's the month that
they constructed and and it's random
Osos all of this connection random
and what do they put for that so they
prove very very - very nice properties
the fulfillment that they prove is that
going up and going down
we cipher bility what you get what you
what is called autoencoder
what does it mean autoencoder it means
that if you go in this direction and
then you apply well you essentially just
shifted going back in the other
direction you get the identity function
with high probability
okay we have to enumerate it somehow I
+1 ability over in there set up that F
done f of X equal the identity of X is
high which is very nice and they also
found an efficient algorithm for
learning the network so if the data is
generated according to this nut or Devon
algorithm that we thought was the matter
how many of you have not seen this work
oh wow I should have really spend more
time on this let me try to spend more
time on it this is a really very nice
work and the skull I gave it okay you
didn't see it so I can give it any score
I want and Sanjeev is also not here so
it's easy okay so I'm sure is watching
live that has nothing better to do with
his life though eh
so this the score I gave it so any
construction it gets 9 and it gets nine
because it reconstructs I mean it's not
robustly construction so maybe giving it
an is a bit too much so it's really
doing this job liam is a bit tricky I
mean I think assuming that I think the
spa cities might be okay but assuming
that the connections are random is a bit
tricky I don't think people in some
people are nodding their head about this
random connection I think they are aware
of that - and I see that's the reason
maybe they didn't pursue this line of
work too much I'll give it a try he does
look a little bit like and that works
well in terms of steps I don't give it a
0 or 1 over 2 because they definitely
thought about it you know if you read a
paper to say we believe that there is a
depth separation here but they don't
actually prove it they claim that they
prove something about 1 in 2 layers but
if you read what they actually pull with
some average
kayson's which doesn't really move much
so the at least we're thinking about
that so you know we'll give them points
for that I think they know that it's not
really really realistic but it's
somewhat realistic and it does have the
structure that we want it does have it
is a reversible network where you can
prove it's reversible and and and so
this is a very good attempt and there
might be something in this direction
that that one can think about in
particular if you somehow are successful
in making the randomness assumption a
little quicker anybody wants to see some
idea of ideas from the poor few little
bit depressing okay so so so what's nice
about this Parnham situation is that
things are very easy in particular a key
property that there is what's called
unique neighbor a unique
in the following suppose you look at the
level but the last one so the level but
the last one by dick by the construction
most of the most of the vectorial zero
and maybe you have some one in minus one
zero now you look at any guy down here
so again most of the guys are here at
the last layer even are going to be zero
but you look at the guy that's not zero
so maybe this is not zero so that you
just write not zero in principle it can
take many value but suppose that this is
not see the unique neighbor property
says that it's not zero just because of
one guy because it's a random sparse
network it may be connected to this guy
but probably it's connected both to this
non zero guy and to this non zero guy
it's small so this will never happen ok
so most of the time when you are not
zero it's because of one guy on top of
you ok so why is this nice to have this
unique neighbor picnic ball property so
one isn't that it's nice you can look at
all the neighbors of this guy and what
will happen with all the neighbors of B
this guy so does its power so there
aren't too many neighbors of this guy
and what will happen with them is that
they either equal to this guy or two -
this guy Internet in in the network he
essentially only have a plus-one
plus-one and - why wait so you have all
of these guys that they gave us these
guys except maybe for a sign flip so if
you want a lot of this guy you can just
do you can look look at the majority of
this guys missed the corresponding side
when you're going to get this guy and
even with a little bit of a wall
collection because there multiple copies
with different sign so if you know the
structure of the network you can do this
Auto encoding property right you can go
up this way looking at all the neighbors
of this guy all the neighbors of these
times are going to be nonzero you know
which one are going to have the same
sign and which one are going to be the
opposite sign it's very easy to
reconstruct given this information even
one is enough but if you have multiple
you can even do a little bit of all
collective because this gives you the
auto encoding
yeah we should think that that's is
fixed and the dimension is very large I
mean yeah I think that's in the in their
model I think that's essentially what
they do because the sparsity goes like
powers of n right so you know maybe the
depth is 100 but it's very very what
yeah okay so that's one thank you thank
you sir so that's one one nice property
that's the Auto encoding and the other
the other the other property that's
that's nice is they what's called the
heavier pamphlet support which in this
case is super nice is that things that
file together a while together suppose
now I don't know the structure of the
network and I want to recover the
structure of the network
how will I recover the structure of the
network so again they have the last
layer I want to recover the structure of
the network so here's a very naive
algorithm I'm going to sort of classify
guys I'm going to say if these two guys
are nonzero a lot of the time I'm going
to say that they have the same palette
so the rule for this deciding for two
vertices to have the same bands is that
if they are nonzero often now not so
often I'm going to say that they have
the same bird and because of this
paucity and the fact that you know
usually they're non zero usually they
have only one parent that's nonzero this
will be a very good reconstruction
procedure for the guy in the previous
level okay and then you do it
recursively somehow you have to control
the dependencies there are some
technical depths in this result but
that's the basic intuition behind good
questions
okay so now can some things that it's
very hard for me to talk about for
various reasons
first of all it's very difficult second
thing I don't understand it and
something is beautiful
okay so we can run a full program on the
scattering transform how many of you are
comfortable with wavelet I know at least
one person in the room okay so some of
you are comfortable with wavelets
so my lat and later enjoyed joint work
with corner a came up with a death data
generative model which is a very natural
models for two-dimensional images and
I'll try to explain you a little bit of
what it is but I mean I'm not really an
expert in this and I'll just try to give
you a very brief outline of the main
feature of this model so what would what
they were looking for if they were
looking for a model of images that it's
continuous with respect to the formation
at different scales so you want I mean
we all know that images right so images
sort of what what do we expect from
images expect that an image and a
rotation of the image will have the same
meaning okay so this is a simple
deformation but you also expect that you
know if you don't just rotate you do
some continued thing mean or maybe you
take my picture and you make this like a
little fatter than another leg
you didn't recognize it's me maybe my
legs are not even symmetric right now
it's all sound of formation you know
that you do that's not really an algebra
like it doesn't have an algebra like
it's not an isometry right you change
this a little bit more maybe my head is
becoming even bigger this is you know at
some point it's going to become
ridiculous but as long as this the
formations are small you say okay this
is still this is still Elkanah okay so
that was the objective and they came up
with a model that does that and somehow
what's nice for this generative process
that they came up with is that you know
in the generative model
somehow energy moves from high
frequencies to low frequencies right so
it's it's you know so maybe I'll try to
dos I mean I stole some so I talked a
lot about talked some about this with
Juan buna who's so everything I say that
- it's because of him everything I say
is wrong is because I didn't understand
what he told me
but somehow
the picture that they have in mind is a
picture that at the high level so you
know there's something complex so you
have a lot of five frequencies then you
go down it's sort of localized it so
this is some intermediate level so here
you have some intermediate frequencies
and eventually when you go down you get
the small little patches this mo little
patches you only have low frequencies it
helps a lot but that form of the
intuition of what they're doing
so I'll show you some slides that I
start from one and so the basic idea is
that you convolve at different layers
with different convolution so you start
from you know a high level concept and
you convolve then you do this local
convolution then you do more localized
convolution then you do more condo
collapse convolution and to keep this
continuity it's nice that all of this
convolution are contractive so they
don't they don't trace the norm right so
that's a more key a key property of this
process and okay so this beautiful
pictures which I want try to really
understand because I explained because I
didn't I didn't have enough time to go
in details but some are what's nice
thing about this process and maybe else
is when you go back there's something
that's very nice so you somehow do
something nonlinear to get from this low
frequencies disciple agency right so you
do some operations like the one that we
do in deep nets so doesn't some
nonlinear nonlinear filters when you go
from the bottom to the top that we
covered the high high frequencies right
so if you can think about how
frequencies do something very very
detailed and delicate and low
frequencies like pixels and somehow you
go up you get
you know this higher and higher
frequencies you get information that
sweeter and richer and and you do it via
this this nonlinear filtering procedure
I expect that nobody understand what I
said because this is very hard so
and III was actually talking to Honda
for paper stock and the question is to
what extent can they prove that you
actually need depth in order to to to to
do influence and this models and it's
not completely clear we are still trying
to discuss to understand what it is I
think might this might be a good idea
for somebody you want to do something on
the interface between theory and and and
signal processing there's something that
one can try to prove you're more
formally than they did but the skull I
would give it okay is realism is a they
then generate very nice picture I mean I
don't think they really compact they
really compete with with what deep Nets
do but the the general is very nice
pictures reconstruction is a little
tricky because somehow this model has a
fixed architecture so they don't you
know like an ad there isn't really you
cannot really tune parameters too much
you cannot really London on the
nonlinearities just fixed nonlinearities
that you're using in just one one one
model and some people have been looking
at it but again not from the silver
perspective there's a paper of Conan and
Maxwell in for Microsoft they see they
show that you know this they gave some
sort of a kleiner youstick algorithm to
learn these filters in a better way than
just fix meters so I'd give it a five
and again the depth issue definitely in
my line and I thought about and you know
they make this claim that you need to go
many layers in order to reconstruct
because that's the only way to reveal
the higher moments but I think right now
it's not at the level of theories so if
you want to put some theory statement I
think and you understand wave like I
think that's that's a good place to go
do you really beautiful I mean I think
if anybody wants to talk to me about you
know connecting these to the kind of
theory of computing during the program
I'm happy to do that I mean I think
that's the oh just do it without me
because I don't really understand
wavelets very well think there's
something there to do that's that's
interesting questions all right good
okay so from now on I'm going to tell
you about my own stuff which you should
lower all the grades I'm going to give
myself eleven eleven eleven in
everything so just
okay so the question remains somehow and
the question is the natural earth data
generative process with probable
algorithm for learning the classifier
and whether the classifier approval II
probably need required steps okay so
that's the question that they want class
that is going to be sort of yes and you
know some people have seen some version
of this before but when I prepare this
talk ever realize does a nice way to
explain itself I think this is the fall
time explain it in this way okay so in
the process that I like a lot all of the
people who know me immediately fall
asleep now explain why this process you
know somehow gives us all of these
things to consider opposites on the tree
the father is going to be the following
process the what is going to be color
randomly I'm going to go in an ironical
fashion remember this is what we want
we're going to copy the color with the
parent independently for each n use
mobility Etta and otherwise we're going
to choose the color that's independent
uniform at random from 1 to Q so you
know just two colors maybe theta is
pretty loud the first layer I copied
everybody at the second layer somehow
sometime I copy something else didn't
copy the third layer some is a my copy
entity and for the token I think in all
the papers this the few papers that this
has been investigated we will only
consider full binary trees you can
consider more general to it will only
consider final it is to make our life
easier and more generally and this will
come up in some of the result that I'm
going to to mention later I mean this
process doesn't have to be either copy
or random you can have any Markov chain
on this edges here so does a Markov
chain that decide what's the world from
here to leave and it turns out that an
important parameter that happens to be
theta in this case is the second
eigenvalue of the transition matrix
parameters ation when we're going to
talk about
will it that's the positive okay so now
I'm going to think about all of this
guitar and even one of the reason I
guess I want to give this talk is I'm
very somewhat excited about the fact
that finally we can say something about
depth on this and everything other than
depth we knew for a long time so there's
a lot of things that we knew for a long
time the depth is newer so I think
that's somehow way there's a nice story
about this model okay so is this a good
model for speech or images it's a
terrible mother for speech and images
people have used using model for images
but not this simple using model it's it
will give you some flak that picture
that you are not going to like however I
think when you look at models that go in
this recursive way going from top to
bottom it gives you a nice abstraction
of a multi-layer generative process that
goes from the top to the bottom right so
you know that's a nice feature of this
process and what another nice thing
about it is this in fact was here's a
process that was invented in terminals
data was considered in terms of data
it's a standard model of evolutionary
dynamics of species so since the 1970s
biologists have considered this model is
the model of mutation among species so
having their first name and these are
three different people name and is just
the name and formation Berkeley who came
up with this model as a model of a of a
genetic mutation among species so it is
a model of data and it is also a
standard model of in statistical physics
is called the easing model of the Potts
model on the battle at ease so it
started studied since the 1920s in
physics I don't know is this a natural
process or not like I said I'm going to
give myself in the elephant so I gave
myself a 6 it's not it's not an model of
images you know it may be some features
of model images this multi multi layer
thing it's not a moment of speech but
maybe the sandwich of that and it is a
model of some other kind of data so I'm
going to boost my score and give myself
a 6 we're good
ok any objections
what is the best classifier okay so now
we are trying to understand it's modeled
in terms of all the question that we are
so what is the best classifier so that's
also nice if you know the model not a
motive the best classifier is known and
the best classifier is just doing a
computer computer the posterior and you
are going to apply Bayes rule or
unbelief propagation you're going to go
into an in linear time if you know the
structure of this net then you're going
to find a posterior and you can classify
about that okay so I'll talk about that
so okay so what to say is predicting
what I'm going to talk about in half an
hour so I think some of them I want to I
mean even though many of you of sort of
really really want models of data I want
it to be patience for another half an
hour and then I'll try to talk about you
know once we took the insight from what
this process is saying you know what can
we say about real models of data so I'm
going to talk about that yes Peter so so
let me let me repeat again what what's
the data and what's the okay so the
assumption is the following so my Y is
going to be the root of the tree then
I'm going to do this process over and
over again and what you're getting is
the X
so you want to classify why from the
exercises and again if you think about
it in terms of the processes that we're
saying why is some high-level concept
I mean don't really refine it we don't
do this kind of things that Malad does
that of losing high frequencies it's all
of the same complexity but we do
localize it right so we move it left and
right left and right left and right up
lick it with some noise and then we have
the X and you want to refer the way
thank you so the best classifier of Y
given X is just doing belief propagation
it sounds in linear time it's optimal we
know everything about it oh good
very boring what about so this is all
old what about provable algorithms for
learning the classifier so this is also
something that's known for many years
this problems in biology of building
these three is given sample so more
about it like the problem of given
samples of X even with other why learn
the structure
this problem is called is a big a and
computational biology it's called
phylogenetics people have done this in
an applied way for my needs but we also
have theory as a feminist paper of
elders still secondly and well know I
think we all know is hero going to be
here in the next week or something you
can talk to her so they have a
polynomial time algorithm for learning
the graphical model then you know their
model they find work but I started about
phase transition for some complexity
between logarithmic and polynomial
Walkabout back learning we know how to
learn this model so in terms of the
reconstruction score I give it a 9 and
again the reason I gave it a 9 and I
don't give it a 10 is this algorithm
says somehow to pass but they're not
completely robust you want some more
Busters so I'll give it a night okay so
I told you some old news this process
goes back to the 1920s this algorithm to
go back like 10 or 15 years ago what
aspect I didn't tell aspect I didn't
tell you is about dips but I'm going to
tell you about the dips is it really do
you really need depth so the question
that we are so self dearly needed depth
in order to infer why for mix
okay so let's think a little bit about
the day what can we expect from the
lower bound here so the size of the
object X okay so X is in the size of X
the dimension of X which we are going to
call n is our case going to be 2 to the
D it is what it is so we cannot really
expect to get any depth lower bound
better than log n better than T because
these processes of depth a we kind of
get really good method indeed indeed so
we ask yourself is this reasonable or
not then I went to Google and asked
Google if this is noble or not I think
it's maybe not reasonable at 2014 it was
reasonable because if you look at vgg
Anette it had about 16 layers and 100
million parameters it sounds like log is
the right scaling maybe so it may be
we're happy but we all know that the
neural nets are deeper so even ResNet is
already $152 and only 2 million
parameters so maybe log is not the right
scale so but it is what it is that's
what we can prove for this model one can
think about other models where maybe you
have more depth somehow but we are not
going to get anything better than log
and what I'm going to tell you is what
we know about depth lower bound for this
model and this is a paper we just put on
the archive last month with anchor motor
and college Santa ok so again one
criteria was a what were the three coat
area realism it's somewhat realistic
maybe not for most of the data we're
looking at these days a reconstruction
algorithm we already have and now we are
going to talk about the dips
I haven't in 30 10 50 okay so we have to
decide how much we want to do sink it
lower bounds and how much we want to do
other stuff who likes secret lower
bounds it doesn't like secret little box
so positive in California okay sorry
second okay very good can't really get
thank you okay so okay so I'll tell you
little bit about what we know and then
you know maybe we will ask you this
question again if you want to see
something about the proof so you know we
want to talk about lower bound so we
have talked about which classes of
circuits we're talking about
so maybe the weakest weakest class you
could come
is a c0 which is a class of bounded
depth circuits we send in all and not
gates and any nor unbounded and one
thing that you can prove for this class
is a c0 if you look at any function in
IC 0 bonded up since this kind of great
ask the tree becomes bigger and bigger
you cannot classify better than one this
class is not strong enough to do
classification better than one so we
should ask ourselves the question here
what version we should ask ourselves is
this trivial it is could be trivial for
various reason one reason it could be
cleaver it could be trivial because when
the tree becomes deeper and deeper this
inference problem you can just not solve
maybe why is independent of X and you
cannot so we cannot infer Y at all and
then it's tree well nobody can do that
even be picking up okay so that's not
the case it's not even it's known that
VP classifieds better than unknown in
this whenever two theta square is bigger
than one and sometimes also in other
cases okay so it's not trivial then
there is a range of the parameter will
be P classifies better dunno it can in
fact when theta approaches want the
classification it all goes to zero so in
this situation VP does a good job does
the optimal job but if you do look at
any bounded depth nicotine is a zero
then then then then you cannot do better
than one and another reason that it
might be not trivial and this is it took
us quite by surprise when when calling
observe this is is the following in fact
while it cannot classify the process of
generating the lift distribution you can
do in a 2-0 you can do it in depth 203
so the background say oh I see zero it's
such a big class it cannot do anything
that I it's not the case I see zero
cannot do anything which comes to
influence when it comes to inference
when you go up cannot be you cannot do
anything better than random when you go
down you can actually generate the
distribution exactly yeah
Taylor is very cool so okay so this good
so the statement of the serum that s is
you cannot classify better than random
is always - okay when theta is small
that is the copying probability that say
theta is close to zero I think that's
what you meant what happens is even BP
cannot classify better than a CDO can
never classify better than a no but
sometimes even information theoretically
you cannot classify better than Llano
but there is a range of the parameter
that information theoretically you can
classify better than random and theta is
bigger than one over square root of two
but when X is zero cannot do anything in
the other range of parameter will be
piously per se 0 is also theta because
it's information theoretically cleaver
okay but the statement of the theorem is
- you don't have to enter make any
qualification data this is what
important e right so it's when titles
bigger than one of us Club this is the
this is one of the cases when we know
that all of the statements but what we
know and then after you of the second ok
I will see it at that okay this is one
class let me go to the next class this
is 0 this is the oh you guys should like
more this is it oh it's like I see 0 but
you're also allowed to use majority
gates or in general flesh should
functions that you can add bits you know
this is like you know you can do
software well you will binary and you
related stuff so so if you want it's
bounded deep nets and yet the picture is
more complex
so when Q is equal to 2 so for the
specific case when this transition
matrix over here is it to bang dramatic
so this is the this is the matrix theta
times I plus 1 minus theta so this is
the case Q equal to 2 plus 1 minus theta
times 1/2 1/2
so in this specific case we know that if
theta is large enough but this smaller
smaller than one the TC 0 classifies as
well as BP so it's a not valid number of
layers you can classify as well as BP in
TC Zimmy and we conjecture that this is
true for all K tau and Q is equal to do
this if you want law about this is a
little disappointing because I wanted to
prove law a lot and now am I telling you
that this is zero
you can do it you can do this constant
number of layers or maybe it's a little
disappointing
hey so maybe we we can classify
optimally into c0 always and maybe
bounded the dips net suffice and now I
ask you to keep this bit of information
in your head like Amy talked about the
code complexity there's some complexity
America to go to the next slide I'm
going to do this yet another class this
is also in the next slide I mean so the
delicate relationship between what
happens between TC 0 and NC 1 which is
the next class I'm going to talk about
and I'm going to try to explain the
story this Bob then it gets throw in the
top conservator ya know I can also tell
you about ok so I have a request one
request for the proof is we don't want
to put request for the proof for this is
0 and then so again take things the
copying probability so take what we're
interested in in the regime of those
information is we'll take as close to 1
Thanks other question excellent
questions good ok so so let me let's try
it
be patient for an amount and let me talk
to talk about another class and then I
will clarify the connection with this
this is U so NC 1 is the final class is
the class of all the log and depth
circuits with N and all games of fun
bounded fan fan 2 and not gates and
somehow what underlies all the question
that you asked before is what is known
as it's not that this is 0 is in
contagion and C 1 but it's not known if
they're equal on
okay so when we ask about this is the
University versus NC one the part is the
computational complexity theory you guys
did not tell us that if they're
different or equal right so you know you
can blame the computational complexity
people you know I already pretend not to
be one of them okay and what do we know
about the class and saman we know that
one classifier can classify as well as
BP in NC one for any model on the edges
any theta n eq any more than you know
and C one is enough for you if you want
to implement BP you can do it in NC one
you don't mean more than and C one C one
is definitely you are not going to go
higher than and C one and we also know
that there is the blood cut process on
the tree which I won't define because
it's complicated it's not just this
copying thing it's a sixteen by sixteen
transition matrix that we came up with
in this very specific way for which
classifier classifying better than
random is NC one complete so what's the
conclusion from that so unless this is 0
is equal to NC 1 you need log n dips but
if this is not equal to and C 1 so this
is a question that we don't know how to
answer then then you need look
greatness okay so this what we know
about depths and this mother what the
depths call that you give I don't know
I'll give a compliment to myself maybe
we'll give it a seven okay just look at
it McNab you know the conditional thing
about this is you and see what you think
you know it's somewhere you're going in
the right direction okay so now we have
to decide what I have another 30 minutes
okay something like that okay so two
options I let you vote who wants to so
the two option is to talk about sort of
a more realistic models and okay maybe
let me do let me do this one slide and
then I let you vote you vote in the
second don't fall asleep right now okay
so this Russian is important this
Russell two theta square is equal to one
is called the cast and stick consume him
and I want to tell you it is fresher
than I want to tell you a little bit
about this question because it was
answered it will answer a question that
said ask about about a while ago so let
me let me go through this and and that
is known about this so when theta is
bigger than one over square root of two
it's already known not in this language
but it's know that one neuron can
classify the the would better demand
this is the theorem of custom sticker
for 1966 so don't need a deep net you
don't need even two layers you just need
one you want like two all the data this
one yarn is going to classify better
than one better than random not as well
as BP the better than random and as well
as beep it isn't just better than I we
love this threshold when theta is less
than one over square root of two we know
that one neuron cannot classify the
single majority gate in the case of
binary in other cases it's you have to
do something else right something you
have to take some spectral information
about the Markov chain into in the
simpler simpler case all those just
binary alphabet it is just going to be
Sigma but it's more general and also
below this threshold with enough the
noise of the leaves be P becomes trivial
so there's something interesting
happening at the threshold and we
it's also related to replica symmetry
breaking in statistical physics so this
is a huge body of literature which I'm
just mentioning the connection there the
connection was made by mrs. Adelman
tonight but our conjecture coming from
this given this connection is that for
mining workers poses on the tree below
the KS bond when theta is less than 1
over square root 2 and well VP
classifieds better than random so for
many broadcasters processes there is the
range of parameter when this happens
classification is NC 1 cookie let me try
to do a picture this develops
information here so let me draw the
picture
in the data access it is one of the
screw to school
and here's what happens here so above
one of the square root of two well here
and that's right this is the performance
so let's look at some more colors I
didn't think about this before I should
have made this
and they're now looking at the general
model not necessarily weave alphabet
size okay so here is a single majority
of the performing is going to be up to 1
over square is going to be trivial and
above 1 over square 2 it's going to be
somewhat not a here's B P so for generic
models there's going to be some critical
point below 1 over square root of 2 but
it starts doing better than London and
it's generally will stay strictly above
the 6 again
okay so performance means like 1 minus
the classification at all how much
better you do better than random this is
if you want what is the performance is
the expected value of your predictor and
the label if this R plus minus 1
it's not the picture in a conjecture is
that for any broadcast process above
this case above so below this case
bounce so in this interval over here you
need NC 1 in order to do influence that
of the random this is an interval will
be P does better than random sync and no
one does does nothing now contracting is
actually you need the full power F and C
1 in order to do inference look at ok
now let's take a toll of what you want
to do who wants to escape the woman have
coffee polite people who wants to see
some proofs or I poof IDs okay who wants
more realistic model they're not very
realistic okay so I won't have time to
do everything so let me try to pull your
table okay so I'll give one proof it
wants to see AC zero that's the simplest
one okay once the 6502 second simplest
one okay who wants to see everyone I
won't really be able to show you that I
skip the h20 I'll say four in one Watts
four sir I'd say I mean have you ever
have you ever seen the switching lemma
yes okay so you'd want to do something
like the switching lemma so you want to
do something like random restriction and
what's nice is the broadcast process
this just forcep the broadcast process
has built-in random restrictions what
are the random inspections that are
built in this process that we're talking
about the sample if you just fix the
value to be zero some probably fix to be
one and everything that you haven't
fixed to zero one is going to take the
same value recursively so there is a
random restriction built in and then if
you know the switching lemma improve
some others which he lemma given this
built-in random restriction so that's
what happens missable for those of you
know the switching lame and that's
that's what's going on okay so here's a
lot happening for TC 0 so I'll tell you
so this is an interesting story that
relates to this Lister difficult physics
I'll just tell you what's the
construction of the circuit
so in exactly disguise Q is equal to 2r
matrix is that and take that it's very
close to 1
or less than one close to one so the
circuit is going to be the following it
is going to be so we have here's our
three so these are some huge sub trees
some levers I am going to do a majority
of this sub tree I am going to do a
majority of this sub tree of this sub
tree this subtree and then there's going
to be a constant number of layers in
constant number of layers I can apply
any function I want so I'm going to
apply VP on these layers
yes I'm using the fact that majorities
but I'm not using it directly because I
do know that majority doesn't classify
as well as VP majority loses we
suspected so if I apply majority
globally it's not going to do well
enough you start like the majority on
some sub trees and then I apply beyond
that okay so what do you need in order
to do that
technically Gideon is an ingredient that
we use in some actually walk on block
models is that BP with noise classifies
as BP without noise if theta is close
enough to one but the key the majority
value in is this is a noisy version of
the actual bit that was here the
majority value is noisy version of the
actual beta mu Z so now I'm doing BP
instead of the two values or noisy
values and the question is what happens
when do BP or nothing why do you get the
same performance oh no almost
performance I told her that you get the
second this is a 50-page bad bye week
you can prove only if theta is close
enough to one it's not an easy proof but
you can use it okay so that's something
for LC 1 you know you have to use the
word problem you have to do worst case
to have that case reduction then you
have to transfer it to BP there's a
million computational complexity ok good
and the broadcaster's in this case
actually a second eigenvalue 0 okay so
now I want to try to tell you how I
actually started thinking about these
problems I started doing about this
problem in a more complicated model that
my friends and colleagues from MIT
suffered peering through multiple times
maybe now they'll appreciate it more it
is a more complicated model we'll try to
be more realistic and in particular this
model as the property was discussed and
sticking bound is - that is clinical -
one plays a key role so so you'll see
what it is
so this I have to tell you for five
minutes about phylogenetically
construction finally the construction is
exactly this problem you want to
reconstruct the treaty how to use its
binary and the data is going to be
sequence of colors at the Leafs right so
you have this so the model here is in
phylogenetic in construction maybe I'll
just do it just do another cartoon of a
tree
so we have we have the tree which is
unknown this is a question mark and then
we get sequences of color so we generate
one sequence of colors generate another
sequence of carlile independently and
the girls on this okay so if you want to
think about it in terms of information
theory there's the three we generate a
bunch of sequences and then the goal is
to recover back the tree so the unknown
is the policy of the tree and you want
to recover that's what you because
that's what Darwin does that's what
people in computational biology do these
days and what I'm going to talk about
now is the semi-supervised they're
learning setting well this is more like
how I made I thought about this
connection to begin with and this is the
setup so the setup I'm drawing images
but I'm really thinking about it as DNA
sequences okay so you'd really think
about it as DNA sequences so this is the
tree that generated the DNA sequencer
and yeah having finger below this point
is going to be a dog everything below
this point is going to be a cat I have
some biologists in the field and the
biologists on the field label some of
the objects that I found if they
actually found this cat they they gather
DNA sequence the sendees on the card
this is the card then that's another DNA
sequencer which I don't know the katana
because I don't know where they lie on
the tree if I have a dog dog have
questions mark I don't know where they
live honestly that's the same supervised
learning setting and what I pulled when
I started thinking about this this model
is suppose that two x square is greater
than one way above the the question
Stinkum special then for any number of
color colors under sub parameters on
this model which I can list in a little
bit there is an algorithm that labels on
the data collect ok so again what's the
same supervised setting you are given
the DNA sequences of everybody and for a
small sample of the guys to actually get
their labels
the captain you know there is an
algorithm that Labor's all of them
but in the second cerium has a very
important feature
okay so it so this is this is the most
important slide but let me just like
display the slide over here so the two
theorem here and the some contradiction
between them and it's related to the
power of either so theorem one says if
two theta is greater than one so theta
is greater than 1/2 and Q is large
enough you can label all data collected
in second theorem says if
two theta squared is less than one so
theta is less than one of the square
root of two any shadow algorithm and I
love to explain what I mean by shallow
cannot label better than random
yesterday again there is the rent of the
parameters whether this parameter theta
is between one half and one of the
square root of two well there is an
algorithm that labels all the data
correctly correctly but this algorithm
cannot be shallow so I'll have to define
what shadow is but there's separation
you need some definition of depths in
order to solve this semi-supervised
learning path so let me try to explain
my shadow is so shallow was not it's not
meant to be in a formal sense as we had
that the first part of the talk the
definition of shadow is a little
annoying but I'll give you anyway what
is the shadow algorithm so shallow
algorithm cannot use higher order
statistics in the labeled data in
formalin shallow
so what does it mean formally so the
input the Schuyler algorithm is the
following there's a set of label
unlabeled data and there's the set of
label data so from the unlabeled data
you get all of the information you get
everything that you when you get the DNA
sequence of all of the label date
unlabeled data so the label data I'm
just telling you you want to know
something about dogs here's what I'm
going to tell you about dogs so one
option is so if you want label the dogs
which is not what I'm giving used to
tell you here is dog number one use the
DNA sequence of door number one
he is dog number two use the DNA
sequence of dog number two all the dogs
that I neighbors I'm going to give you
the DNA sequence in unlabeled data so in
the shadow algorithm the only
information that I'm giving you is
summary statistics and telling you
what's the distribution of this column
what's the distribution of this color
what the distribution of this color and
what the distribution of this car and
giving me the empirical distribution of
every column maybe even every pair of
columns every triple of carbons but up
to all the luggage statistics so what's
the key idea here the key idea is that
one of the things that people say about
deep Nets is one of the things that they
need to do is they have to use
interaction between different features
what I'm saying is like let's not give
the deep net the the reconstruction
algorithm any information about the
interaction between features how am I
going to do it just for the level data
I'm going to scream the information how
am I going to scan the information I'm
not going to give you the actual
representation of each object I'm just
going to give you summary statistics of
all the objects that are dogs and all
the objects that are cut
we're good so that's what that's that
somehow what started this war some
people are still following okay good hey
so that's what started this work and
then you know when I started with this
work the question is can we do this for
more complex matters what I did in this
more complex mode is because this is the
phylogenetic model you know you have
this DNA sequence s and you have this
mutation and one one of the things that
I could do pretty easily
if I added another level of interaction
well instead worry where you go from one
level to the next you just have these
random mutations you also have discrete
convolutions between the guys okay so
you know I take you know in the DNA
model each letter that works
independently now I said SLO adjacent
guys are going to convert together and
then guys a distance for are going to
could work together and then guys are
distant cyanotic involved together so
I'm going to do some notion of discrete
convolutions like we do in conversion
and let's in order to get from from from
the top to the bottom in order to mix of
the features and the key fact is that
you can prove the same thing for this
kind of model is this realistic it's not
realistic I don't know any data that it
proposes but it looks a little like a
little bit like running dip dip net
forward
okay so maybe I'll stop early and I
mentioned some natural challenges some
more realistic models and testing on
data one thing that they like I
mentioned this question to shaileshwar
three or four years ago and we see
student mala they looked at image model
that they've this feature and in this
image models the term the features they
claim that this models are realistic
definitely there are more realistic
human models of images than anything I
thought about and they've proved about
the construction algorithms for the
models which is nice they have no depth
lower bound but at least these two
features like they cop they cover and
you know this is a little snippet one of
the papers these models which you know
similarly to what we talked about in
similar to Malad model you go from this
top down you apply some simple simple
per ballistic recursion of how this
patch is becoming this part is becoming
this patch and so on and so forth and
that provable algorithm of recovering
data of this sort again they don't have
proofs of steps but this is something in
the right direction good so I stopped
here I think there are many interesting
questions they let me just mention what
they are I think the most interesting
question maybe is to try to interpolate
between the sort of theoretical aspects
CO and more realistic model I think you
know even in the shallots valve set up
those questions about proving lower part
I think even maybe more exciting is to
try to bridge between the models that I
presented and something like the the
scattering transform I think this I mean
I think somehow if one can interpolate
between these two models and build a
good theory that encompasses both I
think we can actually get something here
something
[Applause]
lots of time for questions
yeah image entered this convolution
between the species like we pitched down
and the cache but can that be
interaction between the two now in this
model degrees and so a very good
question which again I mean I think this
is completely open I think you know the
I mean in this particular graphical
model I'm the only person that drinking
but even if you look at models like
mulatto models there are sort of three
models and they don't think so much
about interaction going in this
direction right so I think that's that's
another level of complexity that you
know one can add and can add something
but some interaction between what sense
in what sense
you can you can look at images of
different scale coefficients are
different scales like in fujian Alice's
I mean you already have high amplitudes
and low and click tools I think that's
not the issue that's not the thing with
the scattering it turns for white so
they're asking what what what
additionally will get will do do we get
that so I think that additional feature
that you get I mean so you want you want
the cut I mean so what they really want
is they wanted a generative model for
images so the generative model will just
give you a wavelet expansion but you
want this generative model to have this
feature that it's continuous with
respect to deformation the question is
how do you do it you said okay if I
apply some low filter a tolola well I
know what it does it keeps the I levels
notable but if you have do higher level
things right you know you would shift it
globally you contract this part more in
this part it's Leslie what do we do in
the in the wavelet what and that's the
reason that they came up with this one
the other nice video of this morning is
again if you look somehow when you go
back in this model all the information
that you have is is low amplitude you
have no high amplitude information so
when you do this the inverse operation
of the scattering transform you get this
this high frequency
I hope other questions
okay so we'll come back at 11:10
[Applause]